hey Josh are you I'm good Morgan how are
you doing I'm good I feel like I've seen
your face more than some of my friends
face I interviewed you with Central Park
a couple of weeks back no it's good it's
good sorry about that why are you so
excited to jump on board when it comes
to this movie a movie that has such a
strong fan base because people just love
the books well a number of reasons first
and foremost I was approached by Sir
Kenneth Branagh who's one of my idols
shortly after we collaborated on Murder
on the Orient Express and at any time
can asks I come calling but I had sadly
never read the books III wasn't very
familiar with them shockingly and wanted
to pick them up and take a gander before
I committed just so that I knew if I had
anything to offer and I immediately fell
head over heels for this insanely unique
world that off their own colfur had
created specifically I was mesmerized by
the idea of a narrative built around a
12-year old criminal mastermind named
Artemis Fowl who in a book populated by
many smart adults seems to be the
smartest character in the series and
similarly I was taken by mulch diggin
was this character who's this loner who
literally consumes the earth in order to
dig his way into places where he can get
away with grand theft and so I I just
thought all of it was so surprising and
wonderful and it had to jump at the
opportunity I think one of my favorite
scenes was when mulch at all his hair
unlocking the lock I think that was
really fun what was it like kind of
sporting all of that sharing does that
ever get energy yeah it was so icky it
was it was so uncomfortable at times I'm
I'm amazed at at people who do like
years of Star Trek with all the
prosthetics and everything because I get
very claustrophobic so if you start
putting a bunch of stuff on my face I
like get a little freaked out yeah but
it was but it did its job and and and
the character of mulch was I think in
many ways defined by the brilliant work
of the hair and makeup department
yeah no it was very impressive um like
so many people I talked to you were
having so much fun watching your
reunited apart series all the awesome
shows actors you're getting together I'm
so pumped for ghostbusters that reunion
do you ever get nervous hosting all of
these iconic actors beyond I mean like
beyond you have to remember I'm doing
this because I I too am a fan so yes I
actually do before I shoot an episode I
essentially do a dry run with friends
and colleagues so that I can sort of get
any of that anxiety out but but you're
always worried you're worried that they
may not show up on time you're worried
that you know glitches will happen
there's nothing like seeing Tom Hanks
pop up on your computer screen and then
his internet freeze and be like how do I
possibly tell Tom Hanks that his
internet isn't working right now so
there's a lot of that but I'm so
thrilled at the joy it seems to be
bringing so many and even more blown
away by the incredible donations that
people are making in the instance of
Lord of the Rings our last episode we've
raised a hundred thirty one thousand
dollars and Counting for no Kid Hungry
so that that is what is keeping me going
that's amazing
there's obviously so much going on the
world right now a lot of change
important conversations going on right
now I know you have two young girls or
are you talking to them about what's
going on are they asking questions every
day every day I have to I don't I don't
have a choice as a parent I mean I mean
if this isn't the moment to educate than
what is you know they know the name
George Floyd they know exactly what's
happening and they're asking all the
right questions
why why why would anybody be treated
differently based on the color of their
skin that to me is hope it's a it's a
new generation that is growing up
knowing right from wrong that is growing
up knowing about social justice reform
and and equality for all that
having the hard conversations right now
is really difficult but really necessary
so yes we're discussing it every day
well congrats on the film and all the
projects that you're doing all the good
you're doing right now for people try
you are a lot of people so thank you
very stay safe